when you see certain chinatowns and
certain like Asian communities in
California when there's attacks there's
elderly people getting hurt if Asian
gangs were active it wouldn't happen as
easily do you think that's true I think
so in certain areas honestly although we
fought a lot I had a lot of issues with
Hispanics when I was growing up just in
my area a lot of the work we put in kind
of made them realize that we can't do
this to these people even though we we
fought each other as well but it kind of
set the trend that like okay we can't
beat up on grandmas that kind of set the
tone for for them let's say they just
went back to that and it was like in
Oakland or whatever I think we would
band together it's hard to say that
because I could play the other side of
the fence too like we also would do home
invasion robberies on ourselves
what people don't know about that era if
they didn't recognize you in the
neighborhood and you're just walking
around minding your own business three
four guys are gonna walk up to you and
ask you where you're from and stuff even
if you say like oh I'm not a gangster
whatever they'll just beat you for fun
that was why people just stayed in their
own communities